qu'est ce que ça peut être trop dur ça
va c'est le job j'ai créé une société
qui s'appelle la ville propose à ses
clients d'intervenir à leur place qui
n'ont pas leur vie ou le courage
d'affronter les peines d'une rupture
il a rencontré quelqu'un qui stoppe une
[ __ ] alain devaud kit simplement parce
qu'il ne vous aime plus que quelqu'un
pour sip
nous on fait pas durer le supplice on
tranche lucas nous a engagés pour vous
dire qu'il faut qu'ils peuvent vous
pouvez considérer dès à présent que de
ses seuls
je suis désolé a sincèrement c'est mon
agent le plus rude c'est l'école russe
de love is dead ya de la nouvelle petite
assistant tomate a prévenu votre carte
d'abonnement tony prévoyez des ruptures
ce mois ci ben c'est la onzième et
accorder moins extra je commets un super
clients ya déjà quelqu'un disait bonjour
office fait qu'est ce que tu fais là je
vais quitter papa bomb elsa rogers mais
dix équipes à retraite à taux plein par
ya beaucoup d'hommes qui disent faire
équipe ans connaît son nom lui dit ferri
il le pense vraiment secours pardon mais
vous n'êtes pas là pour vous jamais de
la vie je viendrai voir une conseillère
conjugale
je pense que ça marche pas sur moi et ça
cette prise ce soir du site encore vous
avez une tenue de soirée et c'est
parfait à part la robe
parfois il ya des couples c'est une
obligation orale ou sanitaires les
traités pour lui cela peut arriver
tu veux pas faire un break plutôt
sinueux les breaks c'est trop gros pour
ta mère un break que ça sentait bien le
terminer